for years I've been engaging in ama
that's asked me anything sessions I do
these every single month usually on the
first Saturday of the month at 12
o'clock Central time if it happens to
fall on the first I usually push it off
so that there's a little bit of Advance
warning in my update video and a lot of
people come to these and ask some really
interesting and thought-provoking
questions mostly of course about
philosophy but also about my personal
life and background my views on
particular things even about Music
Matters people might know I'm a big
metal head so if you'd like to get in on
that every single month as I was just
saying I offer a session for about 90
minutes oftentimes going a little bit
longer I see what questions people have
and I do this through YouTube live so
it's it's streaming and you to preserve
the questions on the side you're part of
a live chat that anybody else can look
in on as a matter of fact I have years
and years worth of old amas for people
who are interested in that sort of stuff
so I'd like to invite you to join in if
you do you can easily go to my YouTube
channel you'll see like a whole line of
amas coming up if you click on it it
will allow you to not only you know go
to where the AMA will be held but even
set an alarm for yourself so you don't
miss it I announce these every month in
my update video also in the reason I O
event calendar people sometimes say oh
I'm so sorry I missed it well there's no
reason to miss it you've got so many
ways of finding out when it's going to
happen and you know exactly where it
will happen on my channel so if you've
got something thing that you want to you
know float an idea about with me or
you've got something that you're curious
about show up and get your questions in
early because by the end of the 90
minutes that I allot for each session we
typically don't have enough time to
answer the questions that are piling up
and I hope that you'll join me for the
next AMA and you know we'll kick some
ideas around and have some fun together